as Nancy Pelosi appears to whip
sufficient votes for impeachment the
so-called whistleblower complaint that
launched the whole impeachment circus is
released revealing definitively what we
suspected all along the Democrats have
nothing we will examine all that nothing
then new polls shake up the 2020 race
Elizabeth Warren gets hip on Instagram
and a judge rules that a mother who now
identifies as a man cannot be deemed her
child's father BuzzFeed is outraged we
will try to understand what that
sentence even means finally the mailbag
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
a mother who identifies as a father as a
mat or no we'll get to it we'll get to
all of that that's it's gonna take me a
whole show just to figure out what that
means first we got to get to this
whistleblower complaint here it is this
is the impeachment we got the transcript
of that dread phone call between
President Trump and the Ukrainian
president zalenski yesterday and we read
it and I don't know if it was the most
perfect phone call ever made as
president Trump said it was but it
certainly gave no grounds for
impeachment but now we have the real
deal because unfortunately that flopped
and the media and the Democrats were
upset so now we have the whistleblower
complaint that got us the transcript of
the call that got us the impeachment
inquiry that's going to get president
Trump thrown out of office and Hillary
still can win the 2016 I don't know here
is the transcript I'll just read a few
little passages from it and you can let
the bombshells just settle in dear
chairman Bern chairmanship I am
reporting an urgent concern that that
line is in quotes and it's in quotes
because the whistleblower is using this
in a specific legal way but I really
like reading it because I'm reading it
just sarcastically like dear chairman
burner minh Schiff I'm reporting an
urgent concern in accordance with the
procedures I think the sarcastic way is
much more accurate given the context
this letter is unclassified when
separated from the attachment over the
past four months more than half a dozen
US officials have informed me of various
facts related to the effort of the
president using the power of his office
to solicit interference from a foreign
country in the 2020 election this is
important because the allegation is
Trump is using his office to solicit
interference from a foreign country in
2020 now we know from the phone call
yesterday what he's actually doing is
using his office to get the Ukrainians
to investigate interference in the 2016
election which was while he was running
for president but was actually while
Barack Obama was president so even that
language from the very first sentences
is actually completely backwards but
what you hear from this this first
bullet point is
more than half a dozen US officials have
informed me so what that means is he
doesn't have direct knowledge of any of
these phone calls or any of these
incidents he's just heard it from
someone else and then he writes this
very meticulously crafted legal letter
to try to spur an impeachment inquiry he
then admits that in the second bullet
point I was not a direct witness to most
of the events described however I found
my colleagues accounts of these events
to be credible because in almost all
cases multiple officials recounted fact
patterns that were consistent to one
another what a beautiful soup of words
what a beautifully crafted mixture of
euphemisms I was not a direct witness so
it means I actually haven't seen any of
this stuff happen but I find the
accounts that I am relating credible
well of course you find them credible
you're relating them listen I find them
credible because I'm relating them is
more or less what he's saying then he
says because multiple officials
recounted not facts not the exact same
facts the exact same time different
people we don't even know who the
officials are recounted fact patterns
that were consistent with one another
what is a fact pattern fact pattern is
different than a fact well we'll try to
see what that means I am deeply
concerned that the actions described
below constitute quote a serious or
flagrant problem abuse or violation of
law or executive order that quote does
not include differences of opinions
concerning public policy matters again
it's in the quotes because he's trying
to spur legal processes out of this but
it makes a lot more sense if you just
read it sarcastically I am deeply
concerned that the actions described
below constitute a serious or flagrant
problem or abuse or violation of law
that's more or less what's going on okay
then it goes on and he outlines a lot of
things we already know about from that
transcript this is the new information
this is the only new information that
we're getting from the whistleblower
complaint in the Fah in the days
following the phone call I learned from
multiple US officials that senior White
House officials had intervened to lock
down in quotes all records of the phone
call especially the official
word-for-word transcript
the call that was produced as is
customary by the White House Situation
Room this set of actions underscored to
me that White House officials understood
the gravity of what had transpired in
the call it's interesting to read the
whistleblower complaint after you've
read the transcript of the call because
we read the call there is no gravity in
the call it's pretty clear even Trump's
hardest other than the most hardened
critics virtually everyone has said
there's really nothing in that phone
call there's certainly nothing you could
could impeach him over but he's trying
to build this up as this big grave
matter what does it mean for White House
officials to lock down the records from
the coal the coal is already classified
it's a phone call between the president
and the president of Ukraine he goes on
he says White House officials told me
that they were directed by White House
lawyers to remove the electronic
transcript from the computer system in
which transcripts are typically stored
for coordination finalization and
distribution cabinet-level officials
instead the transcript was loaded into a
separate electronic system that is
otherwise used to store and handle
classified information of an especially
sensitive nature one White House
official described this act as an abuse
of this electronic system because the
call did not contain anything remotely
sensitive from a national security
perspective so what is the actual
allegation that's a lot of words the
actual allegation is they got the
transcript of this call between the two
presidents
and they didn't put it on the server
that they usually use they put it on a
different server no where does he
suggest this is illegal we know that the
the phone calls between heads of state
or sensitive just by definition we don't
know whether or not this happened by the
way notice the language they were
directed to put it on this different
server not another directed by whom for
what purpose did it actually happen we
have no answers to that all we have is
the call itself obviously wasn't as
secure they released the thing to the
public yesterday and we read it so even
that this is this is supposed to be the
most important new information here
doesn't really tell us anything then he
goes on and complains about Rudy
Giuliani and why is Giuliani in on these
calls we learned yesterday there was
Olinsky the president of Ukraine who
brought up Giuliani in the first place
it wasn't Trump bringing up Giuliani
forward wrote bringing a
guiliani you might see him trying to
push some interactions to his campaign
lawyer but it wasn't Trump who brought
it up it was zalenski which I don't know
maybe suggest Solinsky was being
improper on the phone call but not
President Trump then we'll get to the
three bullet points at the end the big
smoking gun here it is here's my
complaint we'll get to that in one
second but first I've got to thank our
friends our wonderful sponsors at
ancestry you can discover more about
your ancestors you can learn more about
your story by combining the ancestry DNA
test that's where you spit in the tube
you send it in and it tells you with
incredible detail where your family is
from and what constitutes you and your
family history and you can combine that
with what I think is much more
interesting which is the billions of
historical family records that ancestry
has I have loved ancestry for years and
years long before the daily wire existed
I've done the DNA test did it long
before they ever sponsored the show and
I've used all of the family tree so I
like the DNA test because it you get
this just unbelievable detail on your
your family tree your genetic makeup I
mean it's so cool it's something that
you could only get in the last couple
years really well what I find the most
interesting about it is you get to pair
that with all the genealogical research
I mean my grandfather's been doing
genealogy using ancestry for a long time
and we learned just through his studies
and accessing records that you can get
on ancestry that we descend from Simon
Knowles who fought at Bunker Hill fought
at Valley Forge who was with George
Washington his father John Knowles who
died because of wounds he incurred at
Bunker Hill from four Mayflower
passengers one of whom was a pilgrim dr.
Samuel fuller three of whom were just
the so called strangers they weren't the
pilgrims a couple of them pretty pretty
rough people one of them was the first
got to be executed for murder in the new
world there there's a lot now there's a
lot in the family tree maybe you don't
want it you want to cover that up
afterward you get incredible geographic
detail with the ancestry DNA you get
clear-cut historical insights you can
change trace your ancestors journeys
over time following how and why your
family moved from place to place it is
just so cool I love it
especially if you're a history buff
especially you just want to know about
your own family to amplify your
sulci and start a free trial on ancestry
build a tree so that your ancestors
become more than just a name they'd be
combined DNA with over 100 million
family trees and billions of records
only ancestry can tell such a rich story
you can find get this total complete
picture it's super duper cool go to
ancestry.com slash Knowles Cana wles
today for 20% off your ancestry DNA kit
that is ancestry.com slash Knowles canna
wles
for 20% off your ancestry DNA kit
ancestry.com / Knowles final three
bullet points on the whistleblower
complaint on 13 June the president told
ABC's George Stephanopoulos that he
would accept damaging information on his
political rivals from a foreign
government hold on in the whistleblower
complaint you're talking about a an
interview that President did on national
television that's not a we know that
that's not anything you need a secret
SuperDuper deep state spy to tell you
about it was on TV it is true people
don't watch network news as much anymore
but we already knew that by the way
everybody would accept damaging
information on their political rival
from anybody so get off your high horse
the second one on June a June 21st mr.
Giuliani tweeted new president of
Ukraine is still silent on the
investigation of Ukrainian interference
in 2016 an alleged Biden bribery of
poroshenko time for leadership and and
investigate both if you want to purge
how Ukraine was abused by Hillary and
Clinton people now this would be really
SuperDuper incriminating if we hadn't
just spent three years with Democrats
clamoring to get an investigation of
Russia's interference in the election
and moreover this is so damning for this
whistleblower complaint we found out
that in May of 2018 Senate Democrats
sent a letter to Ukraine demanding that
they investigate President Trump so
you've got an official letter from
sitting Democrats who sent that to
Ukraine and he's upset about a tweet
from Giuliani who says hey Ukraine
should investigate the Biden's and all
the corruption that was going on there
and their interference in 2016 if that's
a big deal the tweet then the letter the
Senate Democrats and is much more
damning much more egregious where's the
whistleblower complaint on that nowhere
and then finally in mid-july I learned
of a sudden change of policy with
respect to US assistance for you
crane see enclosure for additional
information what was the change change
was Obama didn't give Ukraine a whole
lot of help and then he gave them some
help
Trump gave them some help and then he
called on NATO allies and other people
in the region to pay more which has been
consistent since the 2016 election since
2015 when he started running and then we
give some aid to Ukraine that's it
that's the whistleblower complain and
it's nothing so doesn't matter that it's
nothing the Democrats are moving toward
impeachment the the problem here is this
is not sufficient for impeachment this
whistleblower complaint the bigger
problem is it looks like a setup it
looks like Russia hoax 2.0 they have so
little actual information here so little
in the whistleblower complaint or in the
phone call that Adam Schiff the
ironically named chairman of the
Intelligence Committee in the house this
is the most ironic postings in history I
think has to go out on television on
c-span and actually invent a different
conversation he actually just imagines
what President Trump could have said in
the fantasy world of Adam Schiff and he
relates that as though it were fact here
he is and what is the president's
response well it reads like a classic
organized crime shakedown shorn of its
rambling character and in not so many
words this is the essence of what the
president communicates we've been very
good to your country very good no other
country has done as much as we have but
you know what I don't see much
reciprocity here I hear what you want I
have a favor I want from you
though and I'm going to say this only
seven times so you better listen good I
want you to make up dirt on my political
opponent understand lots of it on this
and on that I'm gonna put you in touch
with people and not just any people I'm
gonna put you in touch with Attorney
General the United States my attorney
general bill Barr
he's got the whole weight of the
American law enforcement behind him and
I'm gonna put you in touch with Rudy
you're gonna love him
me you know what I'm asking and so I'm
only gonna say this a few more times in
a few more ways and by the way don't
call me again
I'll call you when you've done what I
asked none of that happened
Trump didn't say any of that you can
read the transcript it came out
yesterday that is completely fictional
Adam Schiff just made that up in his
head and then said it out loud as though
that was what Trump said and he's doing
that because what Trump said doesn't
implicate him in any crimes what Trump
said is not impeachable the fact that
Adam Schiff has to do this tells you
everything you need to know they've got
nothing if they had something they would
read what they have but they have
nothing so they have to read what Adam
Schiff makes up nevertheless the
majority in the house is now backing
some form of impeachment the Devils in
the details here though and new polls
show this could be absolutely dangerous
it could be disastrous for Democrats and
could be very good news for the
president but you got to see how it
plays then very interesting new results
and new information coming out of polls
today not even pulls on the candidates
polls on issues we'll get to that in a
second but first I got to thank a new
sponsor a wonderful sponsor pray dot-com
people don't pray enough they don't and
you hear a lot of people in politics
mocking prayers prayer is a wonderful
thing you should pray everyday even I I
don't pray nearly as much as I should
and even religious people and practicing
religious people don't pray as much that
is why we are partnering with pray calm
the number one app for prayer and sleep
I love this thing both anxiety and sleep
deficiency can do serious damage to your
brain and body you telling me high
stress and lack of sleep make you more
prone to accidents weight gain and
depression if people are really stressed
it I mean poll after poll shows this
survey after survey people are getting
more and more stressed out I think so
much if this comes back to prayer in the
religious life with pray calm you will
discover a new daily and nightly prayer
routine as well as inspirational Bible
stories designed to strengthen your
faith and
your spirit I think we've all learned at
various times we will have tribulation
in the world but our Lord has overcome
the world we all could use a little bit
of that religious inspiration in our
lives so we're not just constantly
looking and weeping in this valley of
tears pray calm gives you motivational
daily prayer plans private and inclusive
prayer communities and relaxing bedtime
Bible stories that will help you fall
asleep here the bible come to life
through stories about Adam and Eve Noah
and the Ark the Ten Commandments as part
of your daily prayer routine of pray
calm use pray calm to build a healthy
habit of Prayer gain wisdom from the
Bible and fall asleep to Bible bedtime
stories it's it's so important and we
lose sight of because we all get so busy
and we all get so stressed but there's a
there's a reason there's a relationship
there right now my listeners get 60
percent off a pray calm Premium
Subscription
by downloading the pray comm app at pray
calm / Nolte no wles PRA why.com /
Knowles over 50 million prayers have
been created on pray calm find out why
at pray calm / Knowles Cana wles
and if you wouldn't mind to say a novena
for me alright
the majority in the house now backs some
form of impeachment a majority of the
house backs some form of impeachment
there's the devil in the details so
they've got the number they needed 218
votes in the house they got all the
Democrats and they got one Republican in
quotes just an a mass who is a
libertarian who's liberal on a lot of
issues and hates Donald Trump they've
all agreed to support impeachment in
some form but in some form doesn't mean
they're gonna vote for impeachment might
mean they want an investigation that
could lead to impeachment might mean
they want to open an impeachment inquiry
but not actually vote for impeachment so
it's a lot weaker than the headlines are
showing you we could have predicted all
of this this was predicted actually
Allan Lichtman who was the political
scientist who has accurately predicted
every presidential election since 1984
he was one of the few guys to come out
in 2016 and say Trump is gonna win this
thing and he predicted Trump was gonna
win and he predicted that Trump would be
impeached and at the time people didn't
believe either of those they never
thought impeachment would be an option
because Trump wouldn't be in the White
House and he was right and then he also
suggested Trump would be impeached and
it looks like his predictions are coming
true my prediction of a Donald Trump
victory was based upon a scientific
method studying all American elections
going back to 1860 my prediction of a
Donald Trump impeachment of course could
not be based on a mathematical model
Krista hadn't been enough examples of
impeachment in US history but my
prediction of a Donald Trump impeachment
in my book the case for impeachment was
based on a deep study of the history of
impeachment the basis for impeachments
Donald Trump's record as a businessman
and Donald Trump's record during the
first two or three months of his
administration that was enough to point
me towards what seemed to be an
inevitable end to the presidency in the
first term now he what he said certainly
could be interpreted as being correct
especially if they do finally go forward
with impeachment it depends what you
mean by end though I mean this is an
inevitable end of the first term or I'm
sorry and I neva neva tably end in the
first term but is it the inevitable end
of the presidency overall looks like he
was right on impeachment but when you
look at other polls you look at other
surveys you show it's not as clear-cut
on what this means for Trump because the
problem is according to recent surveys
the majority of Americans oppose
impeachment pretty clearly this new
morning consult poll came out it's not
exactly a hard conservative polar
anything they've got a good record if
anything they skew a little bit left
poll conducted after the news of the
Ukraine phone call broke so this is not
like new information has changed
anything this is after the Ukraine news
broke support for impeachment is
actually down over that week from 30%
37% now it's down a bit nearly half of
respondents 49% said Congress should not
begin impeachment proceedings which is
also down very slightly it's only down
one point but it's not as though it's 49
51 the 49 I don't know the number who
give the other answer but it's
significantly lower 49 percent less than
half Americans say Congress should not
begin impeachment proceedings but it's
right there it's right on the cusp is
that what you want even though it slits
less than 50 percent sure do you really
want to go into impeachment with that
number especially looking even at
Democrats if we're Democrats support
impeachment by a 66 to 17 margin sixty
six percent for seventeen percent
against that means that not even
two-thirds of Democrats support
impeachment but you need two-thirds in
the Senate to actually convict on
impeachment so even if the Senate were
comprised there were no Republicans
whatsoever in the Senate no Republicans
in the country it's all Democrats even
then if the House impeached and it went
to the Senate it was all Democrats they
would not convict the president not a
good sign for Democrats going into
impeachment Republicans have 5% for
impeachment 89% against impeachment
independents have 33% for impeachment
45% against impeachment the only group
that supports impeachment the only age
group is 18 to 29 year olds who don't
know very much
the top three demographics have
majorities opposed to impeachment even
Nancy Pelosi not that long ago during
the Clinton impeachment proceedings gave
an impassioned speech against this sort
of political railroading and against
impeachment here she is today the
Republican majority is not judging the
present president with fairness but
impeaching him with a vengeance in the
investigation of the president
fundamental principles which Americans
hold dear privacy fairness checks and
balances have been seriously violated
and why because we are here as we are
here today because the Republicans in
the House are paralyzed with hatred of
President Clinton
and until the Republicans free
themselves of this hatred our country
will suffer
I rise to one to oppose these unfair
motions which call for the removal of
the President of the United States from
office the Independent Counsel knew that
the president was exonerated when
travelgate whitewater and filegate this
was not fair indeed it is the
responsibility of any prosecutor to
immediately reduce read release
information that is exculpatory
okay that was Pelosi then Wow
impassioned I bet I could give that same
speech when we're talking about the
Trump impeachment up except here's
Pelosi just a couple days ago therefore
today I'm announcing the House of
Representatives moving forward with an
official impeachment inquiry I'm
directing our six committees to proceed
with their investigations under that
umbrella I thank our Chairman chairman
chairman Adler chairmanship chairman
Cummings congresswoman Maxine Waters
thank you okay so a little bit of a
flip-flop you might say and Pelosi in
the 90s was probably a little closer to
being correct at least if you're judging
it by being in touch with the American
people the problem that the Democrats
have is Pelosi is catering to AOC and
Rashidah Talib and Ilhan Omar and Ayanna
Presley an old squad and squad doesn't
represent America doesn't even really
represent the Democratic Party very well
and at least at this point at least as
they're looking at presidential politics
so the leadership is out of touch with
the American people not just on
impeachment but even on their broader
issue this was actually to me more
interesting from the morning consult
poll they have a new poll out on the
issues the top priorities for American
voters going in to 2020 the top issues
according to this poll are the economy
that's 19 percent health care 16%
national security 8% gun policy 8%
seniors issues 8% only after those top
five issues do you get climate change at
7 percent tied with immigration at 7
percent this is very interesting and it
tells you something about the Democrat
and the Republicans the Democrats need
to move off of climate changes their top
issue when they launched the 2020 race
it was all about climate change it was
all about the green New Deal it was all
about completely changing the global
economy ninety-three trillion dollars in
federal spending that's what they were
talking about this is the definitive
issue the American people don't like
that it wasn't serving them very well
and it's it's way down there in the list
of priorities so now what the Democrats
are doing is moving toward health care
even the President on immigration I mean
you've got climate change and
immigration ranking at the same number
Trump used to talk about the wall and
immigration of border security all the
time you'll notice he's stopped talking
about it as much even as we've gotten
great news on the border we're finally
getting the wall built
we're finally getting money freed up to
build the wall and it's only and now at
that moment this moment of success on
the issue he's being a little quieter
about it why because he's seeing these
same numbers and he knows that's not
what's gonna win in 2020 at least
according to the polls he's gonna focus
more on the economy and we're seeing
we're seeing that happen in real time so
the president really is talking more
about the economy less about immigration
and Liz Warren really is talking about
less about the environment and the green
New Deal and she's moving much more
toward health care because she thinks
that's a winning issue for her she
actually just released Liz Warren
released get your cringe ready just put
your face into a cringe right now and
lock it there so won't have too much
shock when you listen to this she just
released a new Instagram video trying to
look hip and cool you know the
definition of Liz Warren and it's all
about health care she did it with the
one of the personalities from the show
queer eye who is very very entertaining
personality they're talking about health
care but it reveals some real weaknesses
for Liz Warren here she is I wanted to
give you a call thank you
we're gonna be in this fight together
side by side I love the endorsement and
for all the right reasons
thank you so much um well you know I
have to tell you what I realized it was
when it was at the last debate and I was
like this health insurance
racket felt right it did and that's why
we got into it because it is right
health care is a basic human right and
we fight for basic human rights not just
for some of us for all of us I'm so
excited to be sure there's no order with
you - I can't believe you come let me
know how it could be a service I really
want at home we're gonna do it together
all right so it goes on from there it's
so awkward it's cringy but I I have to
say I really like this guy as a as just
a media personalities great on camera is
very very funny it's a quite a contrast
with her because she is stiff as a board
I mean it is so funny you have this guy
who is a professional entertainer and
he's a huge personality he's really
funny and then you have her and she's
trying to be cool with him and it just
doesn't it doesn't work it doesn't work
and this is the the real issue here is
it just keeps her so so awkward looking
I mean it
I guess the video at first when it
highlights it's actually a few problems
it highlights that at this time what
Elizabeth Warren needs to do if she's
really gonna be the front-runner is show
how she relates to racial minorities
blue-collar workers middle America and
moderates this guy Jonathan Van Ness
well a very entertaining figure on
television it doesn't quite speak to
those groups exactly not I don't want to
make assumptions here okay I know these
days you can be whatever race you want
and whatever whatever
Rhian tation you want and gender and
probably occupation - I'm just saying if
you're trying to appeal to middle
America that's probably not the guy to
be cutting videos with that is gonna be
Liz Warren's challenge if she really
wants to take Biden out she's got to
show that she appeals to more people
than just the audience for queer I who
were mostly on the coasts and were
mostly white and who are mostly already
with her and not with Joe Biden anyway
and then you got the problem that she's
so
if she gets on stage with Donald Trump
there's gonna be a Liz Warren shaped
hole in the wall because he's gonna blow
her off the stage it reminds us of that
video that horrific video she shot where
she was sipping the first beer she's
ever had in her life I'm pretty sure and
but she wanted to make it look cool and
make her seem hip like a OC and beta of
work so she shot a video sipping a beer
and interacting with her husband like
she'd never met the guy before just to
refresh your memory here she is
hey my husband Bruce say it's now in
here um you wanna hear no beer for now
you sure yes so this is my sweetie
hello he's the best
awkward its she's talking to her husband
like she just met him
he's my sweetie I love him beep boop
beep beep boop
he's my a my husband's just here do you
want a beer beer is what we human beings
drink would you like one of those no no
I don't want to be religion okay I'm
glad you're here it's his home where
else would he be don't do people live
together that's all it's charades anyway
and she's gotten a little bit better
with the stiffness between now between
then rather in the queer i video but
she's got a long way to go if we know
this about Liz Warren she does get
better she does learn things but she
does have a long way to go especially
when you're dealing with mr. personality
President Trump we have to get to the
most absurd BuzzFeed article I've ever
seen they sent out a tweet last night
that said a trans man in the UK who gave
birth and then soon to be recognized as
the father has lost his case good luck
making sense of that we'll try to make
sense of that because we're gonna be
giving a speech tonight to kick off my
gaff College speaking tour tonight is
the first stop on this year's tour it's
a free event so come on out 7:00 p.m. to
the Friends of USC library lecture hall
the topic of the speech is men are not
women and other uncomfortable truths and
it's bound to be a fun one we'll be
talking about similar things to BuzzFeed
and we're gonna be talking about the
overall theme of this speaking tour
which is canceled culture it's become
very prominent some of us have noticed
it even just this week and reports of my
demise have been greatly exaggerated but
canceled culture is very real
and canceled culture a lot of people
don't understand it how it relates to
political correctness how it relates to
the truth but we are going to be moving
on with that speaking tour try to stop
us it's going to be a lot of fun also
great news we just announced it
yesterday I'm going to be launching a
new show in addition to my show here at
the Daily wire the Michael Nolt show we
will be launching a new show at Prager
you called the book club that is going
to be coming in the next couple months
so very very exciting stuff if you want
to see the speech tonight and you can't
make it out live head over to yah org
slash events
more details come join the party head on
over to daily wire calm you know what
you gets more important now than ever to
get subscribers so that the Kansas of
culture can't cancel us please go to
daily wire calm we appreciate all of
your support and all of our subscribers
we got a new website a new membership
tier it is really really cool head on
over there we'll be right back with the
craziest BuzzFeed article ever and the
mailbag
so BuzzFeed sent out this tweet last
night kids unite I opened it up and I
couldn't quite it said quote a trans man
in the UK who gave birth and then sued
to be recognized as the father has lost
his case so if you were just reading
that quickly as a man gave birth that's
I guess that is newsworthy I guess that
should be a headline but the man is not
recognized as the father according to
this judge and you try to figure out if
someone could translate that sentence
into English because then the headline
says a high court has judge has ruled
that mother no longer means woman so
hold on a trans man is not okay births
okay now I get it a trans man what they
mean is a woman who now identifies as a
man but who is a woman so the woman gave
birth to a child and the judge refuses
to let her be deemed the father okay
that makes sense cuz she's not the
father she's the mother okay that makes
sense I get that part but then the
headline says a high court judge has
ruled that mother no longer means woman
well hope that that seems like the
opposite of what the tweet said those
two sentences seem to contradict each
other until you realize that what
BuzzFeed is implying in the headline is
the outrage that the judge refuses to
call the the mother the father the judge
is calling the mother the mother and
BuzzFeed is outraged because they don't
think that this woman is a woman any
longer they think that this woman is now
a man because she identifies as a man
very confusing
Freddie McConnell thought that for him
to become a father the hardest fight
would be personal medical first to
transition into the man he knew himself
to be then to cease testosterone
treatment so that he could conceive and
finally to give birth when right to his
marrow
he felt nail to give birth even though
he
felt male he stopped the hormone
treatment but he isn't male he he isn't
he he is she but you see how insidious
this pronoun issue is if you read that
even if you have total clarity of
thought if you constantly see he him
father father you just naturally take
that for what it means which is that he
is a he but he is not a he it is a she
she is a she she is the mother because
only mothers can give birth and only
women can be mothers buzzfeed goes on
this ruling the ruling which makes
perfect sense the ruling says a mother
is not a father
simple enough we're now getting confused
on the question a man is not a woman but
at least we're saying a mother is not a
father of course that's true it's like
saying two plus two equals four it's
like saying the sky is blue
BuzzFeed takes great issue with this
they say the ruling has implications for
almost anyone according to the judgement
mother is no longer a gendered term
mother therefore does not equal woman
actually though the ruling is the exact
opposite of that mother is a gendered
term mother exclusively equals woman
according to both this judge's ruling
and the reality but what BuzzFeed is
doing is saying that gender is no longer
a gendered term what BuzzFeed is saying
is that gender and sex are completely
different from one another and sex is
reality and gender is whatever we want
reality to be then they say a mother is
a person who gives birth regardless of
whether she has a genetic link to the
child for instance if the eggs are from
another woman right this is raising
another issue of bioethics whether a
child has a right to his own mother then
a father is also not necessarily gender
specific actually the ruling is exactly
the opposite of that and transgender
people may now only be recognized in
their acquired gender until they have
children but that's really saying is
transgender people they're saying we as
a society will pretend that men who are
confused about their sex or women and
vice versa we will pretend that until
reality reasserts itself in Bialik
biology reasserts itself and we see that
the man allegedly actually is a woman
because only women can give birth and at
that point we have to stop lying and
BuzzFeed is very upset about that
the transgender man so the the mother
this this woman says it is bigger than
us I will carry on fighting because this
is threatening to set things back for
LGBT people as well as for society
gender and how families are created this
slams the brakes on progress in a way
that should scare people I don't think
this ruling scares people
I think this ruling gives people a
little consolation that we have not just
completely lost our minds as a society
and that we have not just completely
disregarded reality nobody benefits from
living in lies not men who think they're
women not women who think they're men
not anybody else in the culture not the
99.9% of people or 99.85% of people who
are not confused about their biological
sex nobody benefits from lies there is
nothing compassionate about lies we
pretend these days that lies are
comforting they're not comfort means to
give strength fort fort a fort strength
giving somebody with strength you don't
give people strength by lying to them or
by treating them like they're
second-class citizens and indulging
their fantasies treating them like
little children no that's not comfort
that is if anything bigotry that is
demeaning that is condescending that is
degrading we shouldn't do it as a
society not only because we don't want
to live in madness and lies and we want
to live in reality but because we have
respect for our fellow human beings even
our fellow human beings or who were
suffering and who are confused we should
not indulge that we should help them and
treat them like we would want to be
treated ourselves let's get to the
mailbag sorry that went on a little late
but I couldn't get past that story I
needed I needed to work it through on my
own head even just understand it first
question from Robert do you think the
media will treat the Republican
presidential candidate of 2020 for
better or worse than Trump exactly the
same people forget people have a short
memory they did this old a bush and Bush
was a moderate guy and he's not really
even that conservative they've called
Bush Hitler they did all of these things
if anything our politics is getting more
polarized now
having nothing to do with Trump it was
happening for a long time before that
largely because of the media and I don't
want to just blame the media because we
are the media in a sense we demand the
media that we're getting we demand the
politicians that we're getting in the
political discourse we're getting so
just as a matter of time they'll
probably treat the candidate worse but
anyone who thinks this is simply about
Trump is deluding themselves this is the
way the Left treats anybody who
contradicts their lies Riley after a
four-month hiring process I finally get
to start my first full-time postgraduate
job next week congratulations what
advice do you have for a guy who's
beginning a career I've worked part-time
jobs since age 13 so I'm no stranger to
work but this is my first big kid job
that's kind of like me I was working
since I was about 14 and kind of
part-time jobs during school things like
that the advice I would give to you is
lose all your pride we have this trouble
these days because so many people go to
college so many people get a very
expensive education so many people are
taught that grunt work is not for you
you're about to start your big kid job
you're about to start your career you're
no longer the one who's got a vacuum the
floor you're no longer the one who has
to do grunt work yes you do you do I've
seen this I've been in a lot of rooms
with a lot of very powerful people and
the one thing I noticed is that the
people at the top have no pride about
this stuff they have know that they
might have an ego but they've also got a
certain humility which you find in the
work I have seen people at the very top
of their game vacuumed their own hair
after a haircut I have seen that's a
real example or offer to vacuum their
own here for a haircut you got to do
that that is where respect comes from
you you won't be respected by only
saying this is my job this is what I do
here's your job I don't know what career
you're in I don't know what line of work
your job is to make your boss happy and
your job is to work hard and give your
best do that you will go far don't do
that you'll be stymied
from Samuel dear Michael is it wrong to
be excited for the impeachment
proceedings I get the argument that it's
divisive but I feel
as if the division is already there so I
can't help but to feel excited that
Democrats are basically just handing
over the election to trump now that's my
read on it I think it's a great thing we
just went through those numbers today
the American people oppose impeachment
they are sick of the hoaxes if they had
not if the Democrats had not pulled the
Russia hoax and now they pulled
impeachment if they had kept their
powder dry and going for impeachment it
might work better for them I don't think
it's gonna work very well at all I think
the people are furious that Democrats
and bureaucrats keep trying to overturn
the 2016 election and silence their
voice and stop them from controlling
their own country and I think nobody
cares at all about any phone calls with
Ukraine and we actually read the phone
call and they didn't seem to be anything
bad on it anyway it's a major loser for
Democrats it might be a win for Pelosi
because it will allow her to keep
control of her own caucus so she'll get
a personal win there but for Democrats
broadly it's a it's a big mistake Trump
should welcome it I think christmas came
early for him from Catherine I'm in my
30s and I find myself struggling with
the idea of social media and whether it
overall has a positive or negative
effect on society what are your thoughts
as a millennial and how social media
affects our society well I wouldn't be
able to do what I do with that social
media wouldn't be able to have my job in
my career and I wouldn't be able to
communicate with people and stay in
touch with people across you know
continents and across oceans and so I I
like it in that regard but it's just
more of communication so communication
is not a totally positive thing it's not
totally a negative thing I mean the
negative side is you get social media
swarms and and social media mobs that
come up and try to twist anything you
said maybe you said something 20 years
ago that was wrong maybe you said
something true right now
that contradicts political correctness
and exposes a vindictive left and either
way by the way you're going to get a
social media mob that comes after you
that is vicious that goes after your
family that sends your death threats
that's and I mean it's just horrific
tries to ruin you that's just more
communication I've got a pretty thick
skin about it so I
like it I mean it I but I think it's
idle chatter to say as a good or bad
should we have it should be not it is a
fact of life now it ain't going anywhere
and we need to get used to it and figure
out how to adapt and figure out how to
try to make it a little better final
question from Tommy what do you think of
the White House announcing that there
will be no more daily press briefings
it's fine by me let me tell you one
thing if I'd got in that job we'd be
having multiple press briefings every
single day but since I don't that's fine
enough of it alright that's our show
maybe I'll see you tonight at USC to
kick off our college speaking tour can't
stop won't stop
men are not women and other
uncomfortable truths thank you very much
I'm Michael Moses the Michael Nolt show
see you later
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show a meaningless
scandal is leading us into a meaningless
impeachment process because our politics
is become a meaningless show listen to
the Andrew Klavan show and will plunge
into the existential darkness of our now
meaningless existence sounds like fun
I'm Henry Clavin
[Music]